Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have an instructive game to share with you from the 2011 Amber
Rapid Tournament. On the white end, Vladimir Kramnik playing against Magnus Carlsen. In
this one, we have a simple fight over a single square in the middle game. It's a 31 mover,
and it breaks down the three phases really well. For about the first 10 moves, it's the
opening. About the next 10, it's this middle game fight over d5, and then it's on to the
ending. Now, this initial stage is non-confrontational. Let's see the setups for each. A bit of timing
here by Carlsen, who goes with a Queen's Indian formation. He ensures his bishop is on this
diagonal before the knight can move to unleash the g2 bishop. Castles, e6, knight c3, met
with a6. a6 secures a Queen post on c7. Double Fianchetto for Kramnik. Eight moves in, what
can we say? Well, the kings are cozy. The minor pieces that have been deployed are on
excellent squares, and every pawn move that has been played is with a purpose. The c pawns
are excellent contributors to key center squares, each in a spot to combat potential pawn duos.
In the event of d4, black's already there. Similarly, d5, white is there. Alright, from
here it is e3 and d6. A new square is produced for the queen knight. Black does not want
to obstruct the bishop. From here, d4. This is right about where the middle game kicks
off, I'd say. First case coming up now, where a piece moves for a second time, knight e4,
met with d5, and this is where the fight now begins over the d5 square. What is this
fight about, exactly? What does white want out of the d5 square? What does black want?
Well, white wants a white piece to occupy d5. Black wants a white pawn to occupy d5. Why? Well,
in the game, knight takes knight is played. If instead, for example, this capture is made,
this would be excellent for white to have a piece occupy d5. Why? Well, this piece can always move,
and when it moves, we could see major pieces exerting pressure on this ready-made target on d6.
If instead, a pawn is there, this pawn can't move. There's not going to be as much pressure now
on d6. It's not as accessible. So this, for now at least, is really the main focus,
the potential vulnerability of the d6 pawn. There are structural changes that come with this capture,
and majorities are created, but for now, the attention should really be on the d6 pawn.
Okay, in this game, it is first knight takes knight, removing the defender of d5, and only now
do we have the capture. Notice, Kramnik is not so quick to occupy this square with a pawn. Instead,
he withdraws the knight, throws the pawn in a pin. Okay, we continue with bishop f6,
dark square bishop exchange, and the reply here is rook c1. If white goes in for the piece
recapture on d5 now, it's not good. Why not? Let's see what this looks like if white tries
to occupy this square with a piece. The rook would fall. It's true, black's rook would fall,
but black is coming out ahead, winning a pawn, ready to win a second, and then bolt with the a
pawn. So it's not a good choice to make this capture. Instead, rook c1 gets out of the line
of fire. Now white is ready to take on this square with a piece. Black adds a defender though,
queen f5. Two pieces on it, two pieces on it. If white starts taking on this square,
eventually black can force it where the pawn has to recapture. Knight d3 comes. This guy still
can't move. There's still the pin. Knight d7 though, and in the game here we have knight f4.
Instead of that move, if white takes on d5, black should not recapture. That would be a losing
move. A good move here would be knight f6. What's the problem if you meet this capture with bishop
takes? The queen is the defender of the bishop, and she can be deflected with g4. Queen g5 is
met with f4. The bishop will fall next, and queen e6 can be met with knight f4, a fork.
So in this game it is knight f4, knight f6. Every piece except for the rooks are currently on d5.
We continue with rook e1, rook e8, and h3 looking to distract or deflect the queen from observing
d5. Another defender, however, is now added to d5. Rook e5, g4, and now queen d7. This last move
has unpinned the pawn. The bishop is now defended, and black is finally ready to make capture.
I should also note rook e5 is not just there to defend or exert pressure on this square,
but defends against a possible pawn push. It stabilizes, you might say, the knight on f6.
Finally we have the captures on d5. How would you recapture in this position?
Are you taking with the knight or the bishop? Feel free to pause the video.
Okay, in the game, Carlsen takes with the bishop. This is considered best. If you take with the
knight, I'm not sure how great this bishop is. It doesn't have a whole lot of mobility.
So he takes with the bishop, keeps this knight around to watch over the kingside. Do know
there are some holes here on the kingside. It makes some sense maybe to keep a piece around
there. And also when you look at it, maybe there's a good chance that you could get into a superior
minor piece position as black. There are a lot of pawns on the same color as this light square
bishop. Now a reason white doesn't take with the bishop here is because the position would be
simplifying a bit more, and this majority on the queen side that is now created because of this
last capture, 3-2, this majority only increases in value as the pieces decrease. Additionally,
to give up the fianchettoed bishop when there's these holes over here, not a wise choice.
So this is considered best to recapture with the pawn right here. And the fight over d5 is
essentially over now. So where does our attention turn next? Well, the focus here is on the
majorities. Does this mean we start going with our own majority right now? Well, not so fast,
because with this last capture, white now has a majority in the center. So black must be attentive
to the following idea, f4, e4, and e5. It can easily collapse for black. He's not going to let
that happen though. He kicks off with queen e7. There is no f4, the e-pawn will fall. But Kramnik
puts himself in position to play f4 now that this is defended. In comes g5, an excellent
multi-purpose move. Black has now a flight square and combats the idea of f4 he's ready to take,
and white will not be able to recapture. He would lose a rook. Another benefit of having the knight
still around on the king side, now that g5 is in especially, are these ideas to pry at this g4
pawn, what you might describe as an overextended pawn. There are these ideas to play h5, and maybe
force black to take away from the center. Okay, in any case, g5, an excellent move here. The reply
is king f1, adding some defense to e1, making f4 now possible. How to combat this idea? This is
where it gets a bit tricky. There isn't a way to defend f4 directly, but check this move out,
knight d7. This opens up f6 for the queen. The reply here is a4. If white goes in for f4 here,
queen f6, and white has a problem now on f4. It's pinned. How would white defend the pressure on f4?
If you play queen to d2, black can increase the pressure here. If I carry it out a few more moves,
let's see how quickly this position can collapse for white. We can have a bunch of exchanges now,
and in the end, black is going to come out ahead. You take with the queen, the f-pawn falls,
and if you take with the king, the queen turns into pac-man. Queen a1 check, there goes the a,
there goes the b, you could resign. So f4 is no good. Instead, white clamps down on black's majority,
each side combating one another's majorities. The reply here, rook to f8. This is considered
one of the best moves. It may seem surprising because this pawn is hanging, white takes it.
What is the idea? This is considered the best move, what white plays here to take with the a-pawn,
but now check this out. We have f5, the f-file is getting peeled open. Kramnik's reply here is a
blunder. He plays queen to b7, and a couple moves later ends up undoing that move. What is considered
best here for white is to either withdraw the queen or get the king off of the f-file. Let me
just put on one of the moves, queen here. The reply in both cases by the engine is to go with f4 in
this position, and even though black is down at pawn, it likes black better. Primarily because
if there's a black pawn on f4, white can't play f4 himself. What does that mean? This knight will
soon be able to occupy a tremendous square on e5, an unassailable knight. Not the move played though,
no queen e2, no king g1. Instead there's a pin against the knight, but this pin is easily
addressed with first a capture on g4. This last move has pinned the f-pawn,
and black simply gets that pawn right back with rook takes e3, and is simply winning.
The reply here, queen to a6. What else can you play here if you're taking here? The queen recaptures.
Yeah, no help here to take the rook on e3. Instead it is queen a6, queen f6, mate in one threat,
rook e2 to defend, knight e5, amazing piece, and one more move, rook on c to e1,
and before Carlsen can even make his next move, Kramnik resigned. Why? There's one too many
good moves here for black. Balanced material, but this knight is not a three-pointer, that is for
sure. Superior minor piece position. You can take on g4, or even b3. This would be my preference,
to take the b-pawn, defend your only base point, and next up you could take the g-pawn,
and black maintains this iron grip in a position like this over all of these weakened dark squares
in white's camp. But the game goes no further, that move was played, and then Kramnik threw in
the towel. So, what did you think of this one? Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section below. I hope you enjoyed it, and maybe took a thing or
two away. That's all for now, take care, bye.